hi hello mr. Smith how are you very well
thank you very much indeed for calling
hey kind congratulations on the award of
the Nobel Prize yeah thank you I'm sorry
you kept hanging on it's absolute chaos
yeah I'm afraid there's suddenly and a
lot of pressures turned up and they kick
their coud up the road I can imagine so
yes your day must have changed in a
totally unexpected way how did you hear
this news well I was sitting in the
kitchen writing an email to a friend and
the phone rang and it started off as
kind of not entirely certain people at
my my literary agents were watching the
live feed come through on the
announcement I don't think they were
expecting it you know they were just
waiting to hear who won the Nobel Prize
this year and and so I started to
receive calls back-to-back and each time
we were trying to establish if it was a
hoax or if it was faking so you know
what it was and then it started to
become almost hurt when the by the time
the BBC called
but I started to take it seriously but I
haven't actually stopped since then I
miss it it's a bit like the Mary Celeste
here everything is exactly as it was you
know from the clock or whenever before
the whole thing started and and then
it's pandemonium that there's no people
queuing up the street it has it sunk in
no I mean it it's a ridiculously
prestigious honor you know in in fires
these kinds of things go I don't I don't
think you have a more prestigious price
than their Nobel patient and the
comments I would make I mean one is I
mean a lot of that press business comes
from the fact that the Swedish Academy
has has successfully I think and kept
above the fray of you know parties and
politics and so on and I think it's it
has it's remained on the few things
that's can best respect it whose
integrity is respected by many people
around the world and so I think I think
a lot of the sense of great you know
sense of honors receiving a prize comes
from the actual status of the Swedish
economy and I think that's a great
achievement unto itself that near over
all these years the Swedish Academy has
managed to retain that high ground you
know in all the different walks of life
of that that is that it honors yeah and
then the other reason is it's a terrific
wonderful me is because you know I come
in in the line of lots of my greatest
heroes absolutely great authors the
greatest authors in history receive this
prize and and I have to say you know
it's great to come one year after Bob
Dylan yes he was my hero since the age
of 13 I mean he's probably really like
my biggest hero
that's nice company to be in yeah it's I
do a very good Bob Dylan impersonation
but I won't good for you right now
that's a busy I would like that maybe at
least when you come to Stockholm in
December pleased
it's a funny time in Britain the moment
does not place any particular
significance you on receiving right now
I think it does I mean in fact I just if
I picked up the phone to you I was I was
writing yeah I can in a statement but
for press release and they're like what
could I say in three lines and it I
think it is the timing is is pertinent
for me because I feel yeah I'm nearly 63
years old I can't remember a time when
we were so uncertain about our values in
the Western world no I think we are
going through a time of great
uncertainty about about our bodies about
our leadership people don't feel safe
and you know so I do hope that things
like the Nobel Prize will in some way in
a contribute to the to the positive
things in the world to the decent that
is in the world and and that it would
you know it would contribute to some
sense of continuity and
and decently yeah I suppose
what do you've been writing about all
this time in a way is that question of
our place in the world our connection to
each other our connection with the world
but is perhaps the theme you explore the
most do you think yes I would say so I
mean I think I've always been I mean if
I could put it a little bit more
narrowly than that I mean it's probably
one of the things that's interested me
always is new this be how we live in
small worlds and big worlds at the same
time and we have a personal arena in
which we have to try and find fulfilment
and love and that but that inevitably
intersects with the larger world where
politics and or even yet dystopian
universes can prevail here and so I
think I've always been interested in
that that we live in we live in small
worlds and big worlds at the same time
and and we can't we can't you know
forget one or the other
thank you well these are things to talk
about on a different day I guess you
have to work out how you gonna handle
this line of press yeah just a last
thought how do you how do you feel about
the it deluge of attention you're about
to receive well I think you know I think
you're very positivity yeah I mean while
it's a little unsettling because I had
no idea when I woke up this morning
ordinary day
I think it's a great thing that that the
press the media take the the Nobel price
was it's just seriously I think you know
I would I'll be very alarmed if there
was a day when somebody won Nobel Prize
for Literature nobody nobody was
interested that that was suggest that
some awful things that happen to the
world a day to celebrate literature has
to be a good day
yes and I think the interesting tip can
be a great thing it can be sometimes the
source of bad as well
you know I think things like the Nobel
Prize for Literature exist to try and
ensure that it is a force for good
lovely well thank you very much indeed
and we very much look forward to working
with you to stop him
in December yeah I'm really looking
forward to it okay we're very nice to
talk to you mr. Smith thank you very
much indeed